[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez vous exceptionnel consacré aux
élections législatives
après le premier tour de dimanche
dernier nous vous proposons deux débats
dans deux circonscriptions emblématique
de côte-d'or la cinquième celle de
bonnets du vignoble et la quatrième le
nord de la côte-d'or une des plus
grandes circonscriptions de france une
des plus rural aussi et c'est dans ce
nord côte-d'or que nous commençons et
comme dans toute la bourgogne c'est la
candidate de la république en marche qui
est arrivé en tête bonjour jelen de
courson on joue 25 8% pour vous devant
charles barrière bonjour bonjour vous
êtes investis par l'udps et y est les
républicains 17 8% pour vous de 1973
voix de retard après le premier tour je
le disais la bourgogne est à l'image de
la france avec une vague de la
république en marche qui a tout submergé
on se dirige vers une sorte
peut-être c'est ce que disent les
projections d'hyper majorité yolaine de
courson est ce que c'est ce que veulent
les français ou est ce que vous ne
craignez pas que peut-être ça les fasse
réagir entre les deux tours en disant
c'est trop moi je pense que le grand
vainqueur de ce premier tour c'est la
volonté de renouvellement
alors nous avez dit la volonté de
renouvellement qui est là aujourd'hui on
voit bien on nous avait dit vous avez un
président un bulle médiatique
moi j'étais une candidate loterie
internet et finalement la bulle
médiatique a gagné la loterie internet
et au verbe première l'âge donc moi je
pense que les français ils ont envie de
donner vraiment une majorité au
président une majorité n'est jamais trop
grande en fin de compte heures on nous
avait dit qu'il aurait pas de majorité
finalement il va y avoir une trop grosse
majorité veau porc aux yeux de beaucoup
de monde m'a réjoui charles barrière
vous je suppose que celle inverse ce que
vous dites aux électeurs en ce moment
faut réduire cette majorité qui réside
en un an - la première chose que je dis
aux électeurs c'est que ses acteurs ses
vues qui ont le pouvoir
ceux qui décident et tout ce qu'on peut
faire les commentateurs ou les uns les
autres finalement ça n'a que peu de
poids la seule chose que je dis
qu'effectivement pour moi une élection
législative c'est comme pour beaucoup
d'élections il ya deux tours il a deux
mi temps une première et une deuxième
la première mi temps effectivement mal
de courson est très largement en tête
mais moi je considère que le match n y
plier ni jouets qu'il faut le jouer
jusqu'à la dernière minute les c'est
l'engagement que je prends devant tout
le monde ça peut impliquer quoi pour un
député la projection qu'on envisage
c'est à dire une majorité très large
charles barrière a priori si vous étiez
élu vous seriez députés d'opposition
on entend parfois des gens dire députés
d'opposition ça sert à rien c'est parce
que vous dites aux électeurs a pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout je pense
que s'ils voulaient effectivement on
entend souvent parler de deux majeurs
une majorité importante très important
très importante mais ça à lille ce sont
des mots tout ce qu'on peut considérer
c'est qu'en france on a on a beaucoup de
mal à imaginer qu'une opposition elle
peut être vigilantes elle peut être
constructive elle peu dynamique elle
peut être force de proposition et je
crois qu'on a on a trop l'habitude de
considérer qu effectivement il faut se
battre bloc contre bloc et à mon avis si
on a un parlement qui joue pas
réellement son rôle au niveau de
l'assemblée en matière de débat en
matière de construction parce que je
pense que moi je crois beaucoup à
l'intelligence collective parce que
l'intelligence que d'un quand on sait ce
que ça va lui dans le dans le mandat
précédent
donc je pense que dans les mandats
précédents aussi bien susan on met la
main mais la 5ème république ça a
toujours été le carnet a bien sûr même
de courson a parlé effectivement de
renouvellement mais je pense que je
n'incarne aussi bien qu elle donc tout
ce sont à ce niveau là chaque mois on en
a pas de brevet de renouvellement
s'accorder les uns les autres écoutez
moi je suis élu depuis si l'héritage
j'ai pas d'héritage madame les élus
les écouter pour l'instant on est dans
une situation nous sommes deux candidats
par rapport à une élection donc les
électeurs vont choisir
il n'y a pas de notion d'héritage de cal
qui ça fait un an que monsieur sauvadet
vous a adoubé alors je sais pas où vous
étiez pendant un an mais ça fait un an
qu'on sait que c'est vous qui êtes là
sur le terrain et qui bon départ de
monsieur bricole bien sûr un mais voilà
sa mère était neutre alors on balise
pour les bourguignons qui nous regardent
françois sauvadet c'est le président du
conseil départemental de fo d'or qui a
été pendant fort longtemps le député de
cette circonscription de quatre ans il
vous a adoubé comme son successeur on va
dire c'est ça que vous avanciez comme
argument en dix ans charles barrière
était l'héritier françois sauvadet voilà
voilà
c'est donc pas le renouvellement total
puisque c'est encore les mêmes pratiques
c'est toujours les petits arrangements
il ya qu'à voir la tribune d'anne
catherine loisier dans le bien public
cette semaine sénateurs devaient donc il
ya quand même un grand accord pour dire
que les petits arrangements les les
punitions quand on n'a pas voté dans le
bon sens et la pratique de l'ancien
enfin de don du président du conseil
départemental
bon j'espère que ça ne sera pas celle de
monsieur l'arrière mais en fait on est
quand même dans la même lignée non non
je pense que là vous faites une avis
qu'elles sont totalement erronés
premièrement effectivement françois
sauvadet m'a apporté son soutient
effectivement puisque j'étais légitime
dans le sens où j'étais le le député
suppléant pendant un peu plus de quatre
ans
deuxièmement j'ai le soutien d'une
grande majorité des démerder des chefs
lieux de canton delà de la quatrième
circonscription et en plus également
j'ai obtenu la mère a été très efficace
encore une fois le match va durer deux
mi temps alors on voit qu'il est
présomptueux je me permets de vous
couper je continue à baliser pour vous
les lisez les spectateurs bourguignon il
y avait un deuxième candidat de droite
dans cette circonscription il s'appelle
hubert brigand c'est le maire de
châtillon sur seine lui n'avait pas
d'investiture
oui il est derrière vous on va dire
quelques dizaines de voix près 22 voix
crainte de voir
et on va dire que vous lui avait tendu
la main depuis le début de la semaine
n'est que jusqu'à maintenant ils
regardent ailleurs
ça veut donc dire que vous ne serez pas
soutenu par une deuxième moitié de la
famille de droite de la circonscription
attendez je crois qu'il faut quand même
se méfier d'une chose il ya la fois la
position des personnes et après il ya la
position des électeurs clairement hubert
brigand a fait une très belle campagne
moi je trouve que il a mené une très
belle campagne comme la mienne une plus
campagne de proximité puisqu'il est allé
dans les 343 comme une chose que pas
beaucoup de candidats ont fait deuxième
chose ça sert à rien parce que à chaque
fois dans les communes dans les salles
des fêtes ya personne donc il vaut mieux
être efficace et non moi j'aime mieux
être efficace est allé au devant des
gens plutôt que d'attendre dans une
salle vide
écoutez vous préférez les vide greniers
c'est votre problème moi je pense que
yade avant moi c'est sûr non mais
attendez davantage quand même dans une
réunion communal c'est qu'au moins on
surprend pas les gens viennent
effectivement ceux que ça intéresse ceux
pour qui il ya vraiment un intérêt pour
la chose donc on voit des élus on voit
des habitants on voit des acteurs
économiques et sociaux
on voit tous les gens dont généralement
on n'entend pas la parole et ça c'est
important c'est de redonner la parole à
tous les acteurs du territoire je pars
êtes-vous coupé est ce qu'on doit
comprendre à travers votre échange que
vous espérez yolaine de courson que les
électeurs qui ont suivi le maire de
châtillon hubert brigand ce porte plutôt
sur vous au 2e tour de cette élection et
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils le feraient
puisqu'au départ c'est des électeurs de
droite pas franchement marqué ni à
gauche ni derrière emmanuel macron savez
chers marche il ya des gens de droite et
déjà de beaux seins vous aurez pas
échappé temps je pense que effectivement
hubert brigand a fait une campagne
courageuse parce que est finalement très
efficace ce qu'a lui tout seul sans
soutien sans parti sans rien il a fait
pratiquement le même nombre de voix que
le candidat officiel donc moi je trouve
que c'est très courageux et là
comme nous ce courage de défendre une
ruralité qui est la sienne donc je pense
qu'on a des points communs à défendre
il y a une particularité de votre
circonscription c'est que c'est une des
meilleures participations de bourgogne à
54 7% juste derrière la première de
côte-d'or qui est encore un peu plus
haut mais ça veut dire et je me tourne
vers vous charles barrière que vous avez
peu de marge à aller chercher chez les
abstentionnistes parce que par rapporter
à la moyenne nationale on a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup voté dans votre
circonscription
ah bah écoutez moi je me satisfais même
pas du tout même de participation cette
idée de rien mais j'observais les
moyennes nationales en bien mais bon ça
c'est doit vous êtes dans le commentaire
c'est normal mais moi je me satisfais
pas de ça moi je pense que dimanche
prochain il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
vont aller voter parce qu'il ya des
enjeux nationaux fort il ya des enjeux
locaux qui sont très très fort et je
pense que il faut bien que tout le monde
comprenne que l'on vous demande votre
opinion une fois tous les cinq ans il
est important les crimes et la laine de
course ont déjà satisfait de cette
participation vous espérez que d'autres
gens viendront ou en fait vous n'y
croyez pas compte tenu de l'intérêt pour
ces législatives
moi j'espère que justement tous ces
débats tout ce qui s'est passé dans la
presse et à intéresser les gens les
réunions que l'on a fait
les réunions publiques que l'on a fait
on aussi peut-être susciter de nouvelles
envies d'aller voter non je pense que
j'espère bien que la participation doit
être meilleur au deuxième tour j'en
reviens un an que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure c'est celui de françois sauvadet
qu'on a beaucoup agité dans cette
campagne dans cette circonscription est
ce que il ya une part de reproches ou de
d'opposition à françois sauvadet qui qui
finalement vous rend la campagne
difficile où est-ce que c'est plutôt un
avantage charles barrière écoutez moi je
vais vous dire moi je vous réfère ici ce
soir
un éloge et particulier les loges à la
fidélité en politique parce
qu'effectivement c'est trop facile de de
brûler ce qu'on a adoré il ya quelques
années quand je vois l'énergie camille
françois sauvadet tout au long de ses 24
ans de mandat pour défendre la lchj
événement barre pour défendre une offre
hospitalière de qualité sur nos
territoires pour être toujours à la
pointe en matière d'enjeux à la fois
industriels commerciaux artisanaux sur
nos territoires tout l'engagement qu'il
a pris la part de dans tous ces
différents combats je pense que c'est un
très mauvais procès qu'on lui fait
et moi je lui ai accordé à la fois tout
mon soutient toute ma confiance parce
que je l'entends effectivement que dans
cette campagne qu'il est qu'il est de
bon ton de brûler du sauvadet pour
parler un petit peu vulgairement
mais vous savez je pense que on a eu la
chance dans cette 4ème circonscription
d'avoir un élu qui à la fois à présider
le conseil départemental a été ministre
de la fonction publique dans un mandat
précédent et je pense que les les
commentaires sont d'une sévérité que je
ne qualifie pas la peine de courir mais
ça c'est quand même l'ancien monde parce
qu'aujourd'hui si moi je suis là
totalement inconnu au bataillon que je
suis devant et cas monsieur comme bride
monsieur brigands qui est sans parti
arrive presque en même temps elle même
place que vous je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un message là un message qui
dit on veut plus que ça soit comme avant
on veut plus qui va là des gens c'est
quoi dans le plus commun vont ils dans
vos reproches il ya quoi
le cumul des mandats tout ce qui est
arrangements entre amis je te donne
voilà est en fait principalement l'oubli
des français c'est à dire que moi je
pense qu'il n'est jamais dans un parti
pourquoi jamais temps imparti parce que
justement j'avais l'impression pour nous
oublier complètement nous les gens que
les parties s'étaient un entre soi que
d'ici des de leurs choses et qu'elle est
complètement oublié que finalement dans
la vie il y avait les gens à la campagne
en ville partout et que cela on n'en
parlait jamais je pense que c'est ça le
gros problème aujourd'hui qu'il faut se
rendre compte alors bien vu par les djs
cette remarque sur l'autre soit parce
que si je comprends bien maintenant vous
êtes al 2 et adhérent d'un parti qui
s'appelle le parti en marche
pour l'instant c'est pas des rats
d'appartenir à un mouvement et c'est ça
qui m'a beaucoup séduit c'est un
mouvement donc avait une liberté de
liberté de parole des libertés de tous
et avec des gens de droite et de gauche
et de soirées attentif à la notion de
liberté effectivement j'aurais avoir une
confirmation
on me dit mais c'est sûrement faut que
les gens qui adhèrent à un marché qui se
présente aux élections législatives ont
pris l'engagement de voter tous les
textes qui seront présentées par le
gouvernement c'est vrai ou c'est faux
alors là vous faites un les yeux députés
godillots peut-être non non non je parle
de votre liberté au bout bon bah ça ni
beau ni godillots ni frondeurs
constructif
c'est à dire que moi je pense que dans
notre circonscription a des choses à
damas dont ce sera un porte voix je
serai émetteur récepteur mais peut-être
pas simplement une machine il y aura du
contenu dans les tuyaux je peux dire
constructif c'est le mot à la mode de
ces élections
vous avez vous avez parlé des gens et du
coup ça leur convoi par les deux
circonscription parce que on a fait de
la politique vous avez parlé déjà dire
des équilibres politiques et des
dynamiques politiques de la
circonscription pour comprendre ce qui
vous différencie si je vous dis cette 4e
circonscription on le sait c'est une des
plus grandes de france
c'est aussi une des plus vide et on dit
parfois une description en difficulté ça
signifie quoi de votre point de vue et
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une forme de
misérabilisme quand on parle aujourd'hui
des campagnes charles barrière mais
misérabilisme accentuée par les partis
politiques souvent quand ils sont dans
l'opposition la gauche quand elle était
dans l'opposition qui se plaignaient de
beaucoup de choses au départ de service
public la droite qui a fait exactement
la même chose depuis cinq ans est-ce que
vous avez pas aussi une force et incarne
depuis cinq ans ceux de renom mais la
droite dans l'opposition la droite dans
le progrès avant la gauche disant oui
utilisant les mêmes arguments oui est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas tous aussi les élus
ruraux responsable finalement du regard
les gens du monde rural ont sur eux
mêmes
ou est ce qu'il ya une vraie difficulté
du monde rural charles barrière bon je
pense si on veut parler difficulté
effectivement au pire une vraie
difficulté du monde rural mais moi je
reste persuadé que les territoires
ruraux c'est l'avenir du 21e siècle pour
moi clairement le phénomène
d'agglomération n'est pas la solution
moi je trouve que si on arrive à mettre
sur le territoire un certain nombre de
services d'aménagement
on peut rendre nos territoires tout à
fait attractifs mais est ce qu'il faut
penser autrement bien rester que quand
on parle d'aménagement il faut dire on a
perdu tant de choses tant de service
public ou est-ce qu'il faut parce que le
aujourd'hui dans le monde rural penser
autre chose je prends l'exemple des
stations service gérées parfois par des
communes aujourd'hui est-ce que ça c'est
un modèle par exemple pourquoi pas je
pense que l'innovation rurale moi j'y
crois beaucoup
on peut tout faire on peut tout inventé
et je suis d'accord de dire que de mal à
la ruralité à des grandes choses devenir
franchement un terrain d'expérimentation
très intéressant et en attendant les
gens qui vivent dans le monde rural ils
sont prêts à vous entendre quand vous
dites ça ou ce qu'ils voient c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas de médecin référent
parce qu'il ya pas assez de donneurs
ils ont envie d'être fiers de leur
circonscription ils ont effectivement
ils en ont assez du défaitisme donc on
est là pour apporter nous des projets la
construction encore une fois constructif
et devrait boire une fierté un avenir
pour moi s'il voulait chacun doit se
voir un avenir là où il a choisi de
résider pour moi c'est la première chose
à mon avis très importante
je n'arrive effectivement dormir à dijon
mais toutes nos activités et à
is-sur-tille d'abord je vous demande je
vous demande pas effectivement si vous
venez vous venez de paris bon bah vous
né de chez nous donc c'est très bien
vous avez déjà bidart oui je sais bien
ce n'est pas très longtemps
oui donc pour être plus précis parce que
là on est dans des boules puantes mais
ça ça présente pas beaucoup d'intérêt
ces personnes mais c'est le débat c'est
non simplement moi je trouve très
important dans un monde a débuté la
chose que j'ai décidée c'est vrai j'ai
décidé que l'élu débuté autour de moi y
aurait deux conseils un conseil des
territoires et un conseil justement
économique et social parce que je crois
que l'une des premières choses très
important dans un monde à député s'est
redonné la parole à la fois à tous ceux
qui entreprennent tous ceux qui agissent
les élus les acteurs économiques et
sociaux parce que je crois que
contrairement à ce qu'on croit
la solution un certain nombre de
problèmes aux notre circonscription
c'est pas les élus qu'on les solutions
ce sont les habitants ce sont les
acteurs et je crois que le premier rôle
d'un élu justement c'est d'être capable
d'entendre tous ces acteurs parce
qu'effectivement on peut faire du
misérabilisme on peut dire des choses
désagréables en disant qu'on a perdu
beaucoup de choses mais je crois qu'il
ya suffisamment d'énergie sur nos
territoires justement pour créer un
avenir qui soit à la fois propice à la
fois pour pour l'activité et le
dynamisme
je vous donne la parole et encore du
retard dans le temps de parole pour
l'instant deux minutes à peu près qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire de nouveau dans le
monde rural
parce que c'est ça la question et je
pense que les gens du monde rural ils
sont d'accord pour vous entendre dire il
faut inventer des modèles mais c'est
quoi les modèles alors par exemple il ya
des maisons de santé en ce moment c'est
on a entendu à peu près que ça pendant
la campagne électorale
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres choses ou est
ce qu'il faudrait des vêtements
pragmatique et que les gens ne râlent
ils disent mais nous on veut les mêmes
choses que les gens des villes va pas
voir les choses de la même façon par
définition puisque on a on est comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure dans un
grand territoire wade tous loi les dates
des autres
mais justement je pense que n des
questions principales pour le monde
rural et moi on a sept bourg qui font
plus de 2000 habitants et les autres on
est tous des villages de gros villages
et des petits villages
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
nous sommes quand même les gardiens de
tous et ses paysages que ça soit les
agriculteurs ou les habitants ne sommes
le gardien de ces immenses paysages
donc on est la campagne de la ville on
n'est pas la campagne et la ville
on est en campagne de la vie donc on est
en totale interaction donc ce que je
pense qu'il faut inventer un nouveau
modèle
nouvelle équité territoriale pense que
c'est parce que soi disant on n'est pas
nombreux
donc on n'a pas deux accès internet soit
disant n'est pas nombreux n'a pas
d'opérateurs bon en fait c'est
complètement repenser cette chose-là et
pensait tous nos accès différemment
c'est à dire les accès root mobilité
santé mais bien sûr énormément numérique
parce que le numérique va nous permet
d'offrir des services publics que sont
les conseils départementaux actuellement
se base sauf que l'on les apports n'a
justement les a pas non les a pas du
tout je peux vous dire brouillade là où
j'habite ya pas un à deux kilomètres ya
pas du tout et le député il va servir à
quoi là dedans parce que noyée au milieu
des 400 députés dans marche vous allez
améliorer cette situation numérique des
territoires où vous aimeriez déposé un
projet de loi ou bien sûr je serai pas
noyés parce que je pense qu'il ya
d'autres territoires ruraux en france
donc je pense que je nagerai tout à fait
à l'aise et je pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux d'être dans la majorité
présidentielle pour porter ces réformes
là et les porter fortement avec mes
collègues qui seront aussi dans les
territoires comme le bien pour faire
vraiment de l'innovation rurale charles
barrière elle vient de dire violaine de
courson on est la campagne de la ville
ont souviennent d'un certain nombre de
campagnes électorales ces derniers temps
en côte d'or en particulier il ya
beaucoup vu cette opposition ville
campagne alors dans les deux sens est ce
que c'est vrai que par exemple en côte
d'or c'est la métropole dijonnaise qui
écrabouille tout ou est ce que c'est une
erreur de le faire dans ce sens là et de
voir ça comme ça écoutez moi je pense
qu'on a on a besoin d'une métropole
forte
on a besoin de territoire autour qui
soit fort oui bon de courson a parlé
effectivement qui a six ou sept communes
d'un peu plus de 1000 habitants dans
notre 4ème circonscription mais pour moi
c'est des pôles d'excellence cdo dans
lesquels on peut trouver un certain
nombre de services un certain nombre
d'organisations justement qui permettent
à nos territoires ruraux de vivre un
petit peu en proximité en irrigation
avec le territoire autour environnants
et donc là je dis encore une fois on est
vraiment dans des zones sur lesquelles
enfin je pense au dynamisme des communes
t-il montbard semur venarey châtillon
saulieu is sur tille enfin on a vraiment
des zones sur lesquelles vraiment on a
des points très très fort sombernon
également dont je me dis que y'a pas de
raison on a une organisation a créé mais
actuellement elle se met en place
bon effectivement donc
vous député vous auriez envie
d'améliorer les relations entre
certaines zones rurales et dijon mais
bien sûr c'est pas forcément le cas
actuellement mais bon effectivement je
reconnais bien volontiers qu'il peut y
avoir actuellement d opposition un peu
entre les uns les autres mais encore une
fois faisant confiance à l'intelligence
collective des uns et les autres il faut
qu'on travaille ensemble veut dire bon
c'est vrai que la ville elle a un destin
singulier elle peut vivre sans jadi
recensé base arrière est censé les os en
la campagne l'inversé n'est pas vrai
l'inversé n'est pas vrai bombe a
clairement je veux dire il faut
travailler encore une fois moi en pole
moi si je fais de la politique c'est
parce que j'ai pas d'ennemis en
politique moi ce qui m'intéresse en
politique c'est de construire que vous
en avez eu quelques uns pendant cette
campagne maintenant on est des
oppositions mais ça c'est normal une
surface et le débat démocratique je veux
dire c'est pareil avec balade de course
on n'est pas forcément d'accord pour
tous mais encore une fois la politique
c'est pas la guerre simplement je dis
moi en tant qu'élu mon engagement en
tant qu'élu sais quoi je ne suis pas élu
pour moi même j'ai pas besoin de lui car
de visite je veux ma vie de cette façon
à l'étape derrière quand on fait de la
politique c'est quoi c'est parce qu'on a
envie que l'avenir de nos enfants et
petits enfants soit meilleur que celui
qu'on a connu voilà l'intérêt je vous
coupe pour avancer sur un point qui est
un point de programmes de d'emmanuel
macron mais qui concerne aussi les
maires ruraux les élus rojo que vous
êtes c'est la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation un 4/5 des français
devraient en profiter
c'est aussi la principale ressource des
communes on sait que ça représente à peu
près 10 milliards par an de pertes pour
les communes qui devrait être versée par
l'état est ce que c'est une ligne est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une bonne idée
et vous nous dire après c'est une ligne
de fracture entre vous est ce que c'est
une bonne idée est ce que c'est une
bonne idée en particulier pour les
petites communes rurales que vous
connaissez bien moi je pense ici très
parce que c'est les habitants des villes
qui sont contents surtout non qu'on
supprime la taxe d'habitation mais les
maires ruraux
la taxe d'habitation est un impôt très
injuste parce qu'on paye plus cher dans
les petites communes rurales qu'on ne
les paye dans les quartiers de ville
donc c'est justement pour par solidarité
nationale et pour mettre fin à cette
injustice que le programme a été fait
dans ce sens
maintenant cette ressource elle va
forcément être quand il va y avoir la
suppression de cette taxe d'habitation
la dotation des que des communes vont en
même temps être donnés par l'état c'est
à dire il va pas y avoir tout à coup les
communes qui vont ne devons plus avoir
aucune ressource bas
je penserai pas possible je serai là
pour m'y opposer bien sûr je pense que
ce serait pas la seule donc non je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose et ça
donne du pouvoir d'achat donc à 80% de
concitoyens
donc ça relance un certain nombre de
choses c'est une très bonne mesure
charles barrière écoutez vous
comprendrez bien que je ne sois pas
d'accord à ce niveau là pour moi si vous
voulez cette suppression de l'habitation
c'est une mesure à mon avis qui est
purement électoralistes bon
effectivement tout à l'heure madame de
courson a trouvé qu'effectivement il
n'était pas légitime d'aller dans les 3
143 communes mais la vente a justement
d'aller trois ans quand il a dit pas
efficace puisque pas légitime oui et si
tu en as cantonales bird ab on le prend
à madame quand on se présente à une
élection il faut prendre le temps si on
prend pas le temps c'est pas la peine de
se présenter dans tout ça je continue
simplement pour dire que quand vous
rencontrez les maires des communes
effectivement ils sont inquiets ils sont
vent debout contre ce type de réforme en
plus on leur présente la chose en leur
expliquant relativement sympa vent
debout contre la faim de l'atteinte
habitations c'est votre appréciation
juste voilà je fais maintenant elle un
petit peu de retard je redonne la parole
après mais qu'est ce que vous vouliez
dire part ça il ya vous vous allez
rencontrer des maires de cuir juste et
bien appris l'art de tailler de plus
avoir de sous ce qu'il veut c'est la
liberté aussi parce qu'ils peuvent
augmenter leur taxe d'habitation ils ont
le droit de faire et c'est non plus si
c'est non mais plutôt il pour ils auront
toujours la maîtrise du taux vous
plaisantez
non non je plaisante pas du tout
supprimera de l'habitation non on
supprime pour 80% des habitants des
dépôts citoyens mais il restera 20 % qui
permettent les habitations normal la
taxe d'habitation et sera toujours là
elle sera pas c'est pas supprimée
puisqu'elle existera toujours en tant
que tous les amis en aveyron par les
maires auront le droit de los
l'augmenter s'ils le souhaitent bon
écoutez moi je pense que là ce niveau là
faisait vraiment pas très précise
simplement ce que je vais vous dire ce
que je vais vous dire remplacer une taxe
dont le taux est votée par des élus la
remplacer par une dotation d'état quand
n'importe quel maire de n'importe quelle
taille de communes cèze que deviennent
les dotations
vous êtes maire d'ars en vous le savez
les dotations de fonds bc il faudra
qu'on m'explique un jour comment dans un
état qui est endetté à hauteur de 2200
milliards de dette
on va pouvoir retrouver le l'argent
nécessaire pour compenser une taxe
d'habitation
enfin on marche sur la tête on marche
sur la tête tout le programme est
financé l'on savait très bien que c'est
long les économies faites sur l'état qui
vont payer donc ça dure pas
sur l'état de les prenez votre programme
faisant vingt mille fonctionnaires en
moi il ya les dépenses territoriales qui
vont être contrôlés de la face au
vitoria donc voilà encore une fois on
remet le remet le or mais les
collectivités locales à l'ofce
collectivités territoriales aura des
objectifs d'économies les loups et les
collectivités autonomes pour aller faire
un pas l'état un point qui concerne les
communes rurales aussi et les élus
ruraux
c'est dans la loi de moralisation sur la
vie publique la fin de la réserve
parlementaire réserve parlementaire
c'est de l'argent donné aux députés qui
pourraient faire faire à peu près ce
qu'ils voulaient on va dire auront un
peu de choses près 1 je vois que vous
êtes d'accord
elle va être supprimé est-ce que de
votre point de vue c'est une bonne chose
ou est ce que les élus ruraux que vous
n'êtes pas sont inquiets de ne pas avoir
un peu d'argent du député pour pas
d'ailleurs si vous êtes le député vous
pourrez plus le donner pour pour faire
des choses
yolaine de courson c'est une bonne chose
notre la bonne chose parce que justement
c'est là qu'est 20 espèces de petits
clientélisme minable à coup je te donne
2000 euros à cause d'un 4000 euros je
sais j'ai été moi aussi me prosterner
devant tout le monde pour essayer
d'avancer 2000 4000 euros qui me
permettait de faire des choses dans ma
vie là je trouve que c'est pas du tout
le rôle d'un député que d'aller
soupoudré comme ça parce que toute façon
tout le monde ne pourra pas l'avoir tout
le monde ne veut pas la voir cette
histoire de réserves parlementaires
donc j'ai là d'autres qui sont jaloux ah
bon tu as eu la réserve parlementaire
avec moi non moi oui voilà donc moi je
pense que c'est pas le rôle de la
députée que de saupoudrer comme ça des
petites
petit cadeau à des amis charles barrière
je crois que j'en avais profité peu
quand vous avez fait vos magnifiques
travaux dans la mairie d'ars en shérif
votre mairie et vous l'avez dit
qu'effectivement vous avez bien sûr pour
écoutez moi je crois que si vous voulez
le problème de la politique maintenant
c'est qu'il faut laver plus blanc que
blanc
dire que maintenant vraiment les élus à
mon avis ils vont pu avoir le droit de
rien faire du tout en un mot on va
vraiment se trouve une situation
totalement débile ce que je dis
simplement ses trésors par leur histoire
dont pardonnez moi vous parlez de la loi
de moralisation de la vie publique de
l'ensemble ou uniquement de la réserve
parlementaire
non mais attendez déjà quand on parle du
noir moralisation on s'aperçoit que au
sein même du mouvement qui actuellement
est au pouvoir en france on sait qu'un
certain nombre de gens qu'ont mis les
doigts dans la confiture
concernant les suites à la sphère fusion
quand même tous vieilli mais non mais
oui mais y'a pas de problème mais
simplement je me dis ça fait ça fait 25
ans est la quatrième loi de moralisation
qu'on fait à chaque fois on fait des
trucs qu'on l'a on imagine qu'en plus ce
qu'on a fait la loi miraculeux tout ce
que je vois dans l'est dans les journaux
j'ai encore vu ça hier ou avant-hier
c'est que le conseil d'état est en train
de retoquer cette loi parce qu'elle est
mal foutu il faut qu'on arrête en france
de faire des lois systématiquement pour
un problème en se donnant jamais le
moyen d'évaluer et de réfléchir je pense
que à ce niveau là je pense qu'avec mal
de courses on met d'accord
donnons nous le moyen d'évaluer avant de
proposer des projets différents voilà
maintenant je reviens à l'élémentaire en
deux mots réserve parlementaire c'est de
l'or d'entre 100 120 130 mille euros ça
représente vu le nombre de communes à
peu près 400 euros par commune c'est
vrai que ça peut remédier pas les quatre
toutes les communautés que toutes les
communes n'avaient pas parce que vous
n'en avez bien rien et j on sait bien
que le député il arrosait les communes
dans un certain nombre y mais écoutez je
prends un seul exemple j'ai l'exemple
d'une commune dans la vallée de l'ouche
qui a refait sa car fait sa mairie elle
a touché 20000 euros de réserve
parlementaire
eh ben ça permet enfin alors c'est pas
l'unique chômage jeudi pardon oui ben
bon ordre on est en général oui non mais
j'avais rien enfin rapidement parce que
vous êtes en train de gérer que vous
êtes trop bien élevé charles barrière il
nous reste deux minutes avant d'arriver
aux conclusions un mot yolaine de
courson sur ce que vous voudriez faire
en premier si vous êtes élu député pour
la circonscription dans laquelle vous
êtes candidate
ce serait quoi les premières personnes
que vous iriez voir à paris la première
chose que vous feriez l'assemblée à
palettes et des photos
j'ai essayé de comprendre comment ça
marche puisque voit effectivement je
n'ai jamais eu cette expérience
et puis après la première chose que je
ferai c'est là les abats circonscription
et d'aller à l'écouté de tout le monde
les différentes personnes dont j'ai
commandé que j'ai commencé à rencontrer
et d'essayer d'avoir des idées pour la
circonscription charles barion un petit
mot je vais aller rapidement moi j'ai la
première profession je vais voir ces
agriculteurs parce qu'ils connaissent
ils ont connu quatre années parker
difficile l'année qui se présente là
encore on a un épisode de gel dans le
châtillonnais dans l'auxois pour les
vignobles on a de grandes difficultés
pour l'ensemble des cultures céréalières
les prix n'y sont pas donc vraiment le
ma première visite rapporte on est la
fin de ce débat de choses près il est
temps de conclure on s'était 10 à 30
secondes chacun dans un article au sort
avant l'émission et on commence par vous
yolaine de courson donc pour conclure
trois choses donc je pense que ce qui
nous arrive est a quand même historique
d'un on a le plus jeune président du
monde
les gens me disent qu'ils sont de
nouveau fier d'être français je pense
que c'est une opportunité incroyable et
qu'il faut qu'on saisi cette chance et
je demande aux personnes qu'ils nous
regardent saisir cette chance alors
peut-être pas deux fois
deuxièmement moi je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de bien surtout les
affrontements stériles et qu'il faut
avancer il faut marcher il faut
travailler ensemble et moi comme dans
cette circonscription c'est peut-être la
seule qui peut parler avec tout le monde
parce que effectivement je suis une
nouvelle j'ai pas de casseroles avant
avec les ados dont je peux parler avec
tout le monde je suis très à l'aise et
enfin finalement j'appelle toutes les
forces de vie de nos circonscriptions à
se rassembler autour de ma candidature
pour que les gens qui abusent de cette
circonscription soit fier de l'être et
que dans 5 ans et 10 ans nés de cette
circonscription là au même titre qu'on
dit fier d'être français dans une france
forte et une europe qui nous protège
merci yolaine de courson charles
barrière oui bah écoutez vous en matière
de conclusion la seule chose que je
voulais vous dire c'est que moi en tant
que représentant de la droite et du
centre je défends les valeurs de la
droite et du centre en matière d'action
au niveau du parlement va tout à fait
clairement je serai dans une opposition
constructive mais vigilant parce
qu'effectivement je pense que dans le
programme du président
il ya des choses moi qui me satisfait
d'autres bien moins donc ça je pense que
c'est quand même très très importants et
moi chaque fois que je voterai à
l'assemblée nationale je me poserai
trois questions la première question je
me poserai est ce utile pour mon pays
la deuxième question je me poserai
est-ce que c'est utile pour les
habitants de maille territoire parce que
je dis bien les territoires parce qu'un
quatrième là plusieurs
et puis enfin dernière chose est-ce que
c'est utile pour tous ceux qui
entreprennent sur les territoires parce
que ma conclusion c'est un accusé de
redonner confiance à tous ceux qui
entreprennent sur notre territoire en
matière à la fois économique et social
parce que encore une fois je pense que
les élus nous n'avons pas toutes les
solutions mais elles nous nous
appartient d'écouter tout ce qu'ils
entreprennent merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté cette invitation et cet
exercice du débat en rappelant que ça
n'a pas été le cas tous les candidats de
bourgogne winglois loin de la soi-disant
tous les deux d'autant plus remercier
merci à vous et il est temps de changer
de distribution comme on dit au cinéma
on vous chasse un peu rassemblez vos
affaires voilà et de quitter le nord de
la côte-d'or pour aller tout au sud du
département
dans la 5e circonscription pendant que
nos deux candidats s'installe
bonjour messieurs 7/5 c'est un croissant
qui recouvre le sud du département du
rural dans la plaine de la saône la
ville de beaune et le vignoble pour
faire très simple et comme partout en
bourgogne c'est le candidat dans marche
qui est arrivé en tête
bonjour didier parisse bonjour monsieur
les îles 37 pour cent quinze mille 400
voix devant le candidat de la droite
hubert poullot bonjour bonjour 25% et
10300 voix j'ai fait ça à gros traits
cette circonscription a été pendant près
de 19 ans celle d'alain suguenot elle
paraissait solidement arrimés à droite
mais il faut se souvenir qu'elle a été
aussi celle de françois patriat alors
socialiste aujourd'hui conseiller
d'emmanuel macron est ce que c'est cette
filiation là que vous avez suivait
didier paris s'en prenant la vague dans
marche mais aussi la trace de françois
patriat
c'est une question personnelle très
personnel non autrement dit est-ce que
ça vous a servi dans l'intériorité de
françois patriat évidemment évidemment
parce que françois patriat est un homme
éminemment respectée dans la
circonscription mais pas que dans la
circonscription nationalement aussi on
l'a vu et moi j'ai pardonné mois mais à
un moment d'interruption sur
l'exceptionnel émotions que j'ai vécues
mais quand j j'ai vécu je suis persuadé
que je ne suis pas le seul beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes ont vécu cette
émotion au moment de la passation de
pouvoir au moment de de contact entre le
président macron et françois patriat
donc évidemment françois est quelqu'un
qui a fait un travail de fond et pendant
des années qu'ils soient parlementaires
ou dans tous les autres posent kg donc
compris il est non mais il est président
de mon comité de soutien c'est clair
mais en même temps me semble-t-il on a
réussi à prolonger un mouvement sur une
force sur un sur un moment puissante qui
a été générée par emmanuel macron et
puis ensuite encore faut-il que le
candidat que je suis puisse incarner ce
mouvement ça va être le thème de la
débâcle berclau vous vous attendiez à
dire une vague d'une telle force quand
vous vous êtes lancé dans dans cette
aventure législatives alors en toute
honnêteté on savait que ces élections
elle est très difficile dans la foulée
de la présidentielle tout à fait au vu
du constat national qu'on avait pu avoir
on savait que ça allait être difficile
mais en toute honnêteté pas avec cette
différence de marche
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ces élections
du premier tour des législatives il ya
un engouement au niveau national et bien
sûr qu'ils se reportent sur nos
territoires de la côte d'or et bien
d'autres territoires qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on l'a entendu
il ya un président de la république qui
a été élu que l'on reconnaît bien
entendu que je lui souhaite
personnellement de réussir dans
l'intérêt de notre france et que
l'engouement qui étaient là ont continué
à donner les mêmes effets surtout que je
souhaite de réussir ça veut dire que
dans cette campagne on doit comprendre
que vous vous situez pas forcément dans
une opposition ferme où on sait des
voeux républicain et non je ne suis pas
effectivement ses voeux aujourd'hui un
parlementaire que je suis que je serai
je pense dimanche soir c'est aussi
défendre un intérêt du pays et de son
territoire
c'est ce qui prime avant tout alors
c'est vrai que pour revenir sur la
question de départ on a vu cette cette
campagne électorale avec ses fameuses
affiches où certains m'ont un petit peu
gentiment fait la remarque pourquoi
j'étais en photo avec mon ami alain
suguenot
mais je fais la même remarque pourquoi
notre président de la république est en
photo avec monsieur pâris je balise
comme j'ai fait tout à l'heure pour
l'ensemble de vos réunions
alain suguenot et est depuis trois
mandats depuis il s'est fait irruption
il a décidé in extremis finalement
dernier moment vertus du cumul des
mandats de choisir sa ville de beaune
plutôt que les législatives c'est donc
vous qui êtes le candidat et lui le
suppléant effectivement il a fait la
campagne avec vous à la série no 7 a
fait ce que vous nous dites là c'est que
certains vous ont reproché on va dire
d'être avec lui tout le temps d'être
avec lui c'est à dire ça fait des années
aussi qu'on travaille ensemble et
aujourd'hui c'est la position d'alain
suguenot elle s'expliquait par rapport à
la loi du nil en cumul des mandats et
pour éviter certainement de se dire je
vais tirer d'un côté ou de l'autre
je vais prendre tout simplement mon
super et on va travailler ensemble qui
je connais ce territoire j'y suis né sur
ce territoire
je connais parfaitement les 225 commune
ce qui veut dire que c'était légitime
que je parte avec lui il m'a fait cette
proposition là réfléchi ensemble et on a
décidé effectivement de menus campagne
alors vous parlez d afficher de vaud
affiche à vous parce que vous vous étiez
à côté d' emmanuel macron c'est ça que
vous voulez dire oui enfin
je pense pas qu'il y ait de confusion
dans l'esprit des électeurs de la
cinquième sur qui était le candidat
je crois qu'aucun d'entre eux n'a cru
que ça pouvait et emmanuel macron par
contre franchement je vais vous dire
monsieur les jeux ne souhaitait pas
aborder ce débat parce que dans la
campagne a été propre et moi je n'ai
jamais attaqué mes adversaires qui sont
pas des ennemis et je salue hubert
poullot qui a fait la même chose donc à
pas difficultés nées au moins puisqu'il
aborde lui même le thème je le fais moi
aussi réellement un monsieur paulo et ça
ça a choqué ça fait pas que interrogé ça
a choqué bon nombre d'électeurs pourquoi
c'est pas que vous soyez ensemble
que vous soyez ensemble que vous ayez
décidé à était suppléant l'autre
titulaire l'un devient titulaire l'aude
supérieur mythe pourquoi pas non ce qui
est ce qui a pu choquer les adversaires
emplois réellement nous c'est qu'à un
moment il fallait vraiment s'approcher à
20 centimètres de la fiche pour voir qui
était réellement le candidat et qui
était réellement le supplanter dans mon
esprit vous avez utilisé finalement des
méthodes d'un autre âge qui me semblait
quasiment impossible de voir ressurgir
vous l'avez fait resurgir libre à vous
je suis pas certain que le résultat de
dimanche soir n'est pas pour partie
sanctionner ce type de pratique aucune
réponse de leur poule alors déjà rêvé
par les premiers quand vous dites que
vous n'êtes pas d'accord je le conçois
ce qui n'empêche que il faut quand même
reconnaître que il ya bien fallu et on
n'était pas les seuls au niveau national
au niveau de cette réglementation qui
s'applique est c'est vrai que c'était
une découverte pour les électeurs ben
dhia ben oui pourquoi parler du non
cumul la nuit du non-cumul mais il
fallait s'adapter s'adapter la solution
alain suguenot la prise après une longue
réflexion
cette deal effectivement je peux
difficilement laisser mon territoire de
beaune au profit de l'âge du vote du
parlement l'éthique c'est votre choix
politique c'est je comptais silence est
hélas ce que je conteste c'est la clarté
de votre démarche ailleurs les électeurs
c'est tout à m'attarder après on
s'arrête là moi je dis ce que j'avais en
toute honnêteté ça a été clair
même des publications dans la presse il
ya eu effectivement nos bulletins
d'information que vous le savez tv s'est
redécouvert bloquer tel candidat je
verrier nollet cessèrent de revenir sur
ce thème en dit assez long
un mot sur l'arithmétique électorale de
votre circonscription
quand on regarde le résultat du premier
tour robert poulot où est ce que vous
espérez on va dire refaire votre retard
dans l'abstention qui était plus forte
que dans la circonscription précédente
chez vous et ne plus y avait aussi 7000
voix du front national dans cette
circonscription
vous faites quoi dans cet entre deux
tours vous allez les chercher où les
voix et bien en toute honnêteté je vais
les chercher dans les dents
l'associationnisme déjà dans les zones
principalement qui sont installés sur
les zones rurales
on a vu quand même cette différence de
voix sur la ville de beaune qui était
effectivement qu'ils pouvaient aussi
s'en explique et par rapport à votre
présence que vous faites quand même
partie des personnes vous êtes quand
même connu sur la ville de beaune et
reid
tout à fait mais ce qui n'empêche que
aujourd'hui sur notre cinquième
circonscription 225 commune je le
rappelle avec des territoires très
diversifié avec des territoires ruraux
par rapport au val de saône et par
rapport à toute la partie auxois ces
gens là aujourd'hui son sont dans la
difficulté et on comprend aussi le
réaction de d'apporter des votes comme
on les appelle couramment depuis
quelques années des votes sanction par
rapport aux différents gouvernements au
gouvernement qui se sont suivies
et puis en se disant finalement on est
nous abandonnée du territoire
ces gens-là nationale il va
effectivement mais aujourd'hui deuxième
tour des législatives
on est tous au cid avec le même objectif
défendre un territoire défendre notre
pays
soutenir notre pays donc le aujourd'hui
je fais appel effectivement à tous les
gens qui ont souhaité qu'ils souhaitent
se reconnaît dans les propositions que
nous les républicains on avance de façon
à pouvoir construire ce nouveau payer la
vérité c'est que ce que vous jouez en
défense vous attend dès le deuxième tour
non la vérité c'est que nous avons
un programme politique une force
politique large un arc politique comme
on n'a jamais vu ou en vue en tout cas
moi je suis encore un jeune homme mais
j'en ai pas le souvenir est clairement
oui certes et une abstention on peut le
déplorer c'est une question de
fonctionnement la démocratie en général
mais en même temps me semble-t-il
beaucoup d'électeurs se sont ils vont
encore se retrouver sur une proposition
politique qui permet à la droite et à la
gauche panini mai et à la droite et à la
gauche de s'y retrouver assez facilement
c'est quoi c'est une proposition du
mouvement est ce une proposition de la
protection une proposition de la liberté
une proposition d'un protection
franchement y compris sur nos
territoires hubert poullot vous l'avez
vous les connaissez je les connais aussi
on a des zones un peu urbaine un peu
rural ainsi de suite beaucoup de gens
ont besoin de deux de ses deux pieds
pour continuer à avancer de ces deux
logiques une logique de protection une
logique de développement
voilà et me semble utile les réserves de
voix que nous avons mangé je ne je ne
devine pas ce que les lecteurs fera à
maturité en ait beaucoup parce que les
dynamiques de faible participation elle
se modifiera mois entre le lieu-dit le
deuxième tour dans une élection c'est un
gars bien sûr sauf que après si c'est la
politique stricte faisons l'accumulation
des votes qui se sont portés sur sur nos
deux candidatures et puis les autres je
vois assez mal qui aura l'intention de
se reporter sur la candidature du
candidat des républicains au deuxième
tour si tous un petit mot rapide sur un
fait pardonner - a fait campagne qui
s'est produit entre hier et aujourd'hui
dans votre circonscription c'est l'envoi
de profession de foi par le front du
candidat front national alors qu'il
n'est pas qualifier au deuxième tour
vous vous vous appréhendé cette
situation comment ça peut provoquer un
recours vous préférez on va dire ne pas
vous en occupez hubert poullot est dit
par ici tous les deux rapidement un
cocon qu'on aborde quand même ce sujet
effectivement depuis 48 heures on a
découvert
cette distribution de l'information que
je peux je peux personnellement
considérer erreurs mais ce qui n'empêche
que la responsabilité en porte aux
candidats qui a fait distribuer ces
documents et qui effectivement
aujourd'hui je suis en grande réflexion
de voir s'il faudra pas avoir déposé des
recours puisque on peut pas ignorer que
ce type d'information à tort va
perturber les lecteurs qui dimanche
croyant avoir trois candidats n'a
finalement officiellement que deux
départs et on peut être d'accord tous
les deux à une ou deux réserves près la
première c'est que j'ai cru au début
franchement entre nous et j'ai cru le
répétez pas j'ai cru au début que
c'était une manipulation du front
national elle aurait était gravissime
parce que effectivement hubert paulois
raison ça a mené une situation où les
lecteurs les lecteurs pouvaient rentrer
dans cette confusion
elle était grave aussi parce que il y
avait une conjonction d'éléments sur
l'appel à une manifestation publique qui
était un mauvais moment au mauvais
endroit bon j'ai immédiatement prévenu
les services de l'état en disant
attention
une situation qui une situation au plan
du fonctionnement démocratique d'abord
et de l'ordre public ensuite bien
ensuite
le responsable du front national a donné
les explications qu'il voulait bien
donnez moi je ne sente pas les âmes
je sais pas quelle a été la réalité ce
que je constate aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
est clairement revenu en arrière en
disant c'est une erreur j'avais envoyé
sa pensant que je serai au deuxième tour
ce que je relève sur ce point pardonnez
moi mais c'est inconcevable
c'est inconcevable de penser que le
choix de l'électeur et déjà fait enfin
c'est une folie à l'état pur moi je
respecte les électeurs j'ai attendu le
soir de deuxième tour pour savoir ce
qu'il convenait de faire ce qui me
convenait de dire ça me par une paire
évidence on est dans une démocratie et
dernier point
j'entends bertolo dire je me réserve sur
les recours et autres alors ouais ça
m'interroge autrement parce que je me
dis à qui profite le crime tout
simplement enfin moi je vois pas quel
type de recours v affiche il ya que deux
personnes sur les affiches des
professions de foi
les gens n'en recevront que 200 faa
imaginer ce que je je vous regarde je
peux pas envisager une seule seconde que
vous ayez des idées dans la tête sur ce
terrain là moi j'en sais rien laisser
passer par des brevets j'ai réfléchi
parce que ça peut avoir des conséquences
qui sont dès qu'elles les libèrent paulo
lesquelles tout simplement à perturber
les lecteurs mais là aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui à donner des noms mais le
vote a lieu dimanche america dimanche
soir on constate un résultat qui est
très minimes entre qui et qui
entre le front national et la nana comme
sommes deux candidats au 2è reg
sauf erreur de ma part oui on incarne un
résultat qui est tr min l'accord donc
c'est la question en a le droit de se la
poser est-ce que effectivement avec
cette petite différence qu'on peut
constater dimanche soir dans un sens
comme dans l'autre
d'ailleurs monsieur paris seuil un sens
comme dans l'autre ça peut effectivement
nous interpeller par rapport à celles
habilitées chacun parle je ne voudrais
pas on va vous le demande et dimanche
sont rassurés joindre à ce que vous
ferez dit réellement je n'aimerais pas
mais vraiment pas et je pense que nos
électeurs pas plus considérer que le
front national pourrait d'une quelconque
façon larbitre du deuxième tour des
élections législatives point là vous
semblez pouvoir tomber d'accord là
dessus on je me suis expliqué effective
et arbitre les vendent aux urnes
ou si vous ou moi que je vais aller
chercher mieux c'est dans les açores les
alertant lyon arbitres dans l'hygiène ou
sur tapis vert
c'est pas mieux peut-être ça c'est votre
marque nous appartient on avance il nous
reste un petit quart d'heure démission
parce que ça nous aura pris du temps
mais c'est important d'en parler parce
que c'est quelque chose qui se passe en
ce moment et est aujourd'hui même dans
votre circonscription
on parle un peu de votre circonscription
je disais tout à l'heure rural beaunoise
et viticole heures on a beaucoup parlé
de rural tout à l'heure dans la
quatrième c'est vrai qu'à une partie
rurale et vous en parliez il ya là pour
la plaine de la saône et à l'eau soit il
ya une spécificité quand même dans votre
circonscription c'est les vignobles les
plus prestigieux de bourgogne c'est la
soeur il y en a dans le chalonnais bien
sûr un peu dans le châtillonnais mais
c'est vraiment et le chablisien bien sûr
on est vraiment au coeur on sait qu' il
ya une lutte en ce moment entre les
organismes qui essaie de lutter contre
l'alcoolisme et les addictions et puis
le monde viticole qui essaient d'obtenir
on va dire une forme d'exception pour
communiquer il y avait une particularité
avec emmanuel macron c'est qu'une de ses
conseillères elle est issue d'un lobby
provins de vin et société
est ce que ça veut dire que dans votre
camp c'est la fin de la loi evin que
vous êtes en faveur du monde viticole et
que les choses ont changé par rapport
aux années précédentes et que vous êtes
allez dire ça aux vignerons de la côte
déjà je sais pas si une conseiller en
aussi proches aux atten de l'elysée fait
la politique nationale en la matière qu
à l a été affichée pendant la campagne
pour que le monde viticole le sache bien
certes mais certes mais ne faisons pas d
assimilation trop ras des raccourcis
deuxième point je pense est un vrai
sujet est sérieux c'est à dire que allez
allez défendre la viticulture qui qu'il
ne le fera pas quel que soit l'élu
parlementaire ou pas parlementaire c'est
évident c'est quand même lépine dorsale
de notre économie
la 5e circonscription est largement
au-delà c'est c'est quand même enfin
c'est une fierté nationale c'est une
fierté interne dont il ya aucun doute
tout ce qui sera fait pour aider pour
protéger la viticulture bourguignonne
sera fait quel que soit le candidat soit
ils ont certains après il ya une
inflexion de la loi evin ce sera une
discuterait clamé par monde viticole et
aux programmes des manuels macro et
d'edouard philippe clairement à ma
connaissance pas à ce stade
tandis qu'à son vin
cent vingt mesures je suis pas certain
que on peut poser beaucoup de questions
qui seront pas strictement des mes yeux
la question parce que je pense que vous
avez rencontré le monde viticole ils
vous ont posé la question et que vous
avez déjà dû leur faire une réponse tous
les deux d'ailleurs c'est chacun son
tour savez tout simplement une question
de débat c'est à dire qu'il forme mesuré
par rapport il c'était quoi la
préoccupation la loi evin initiale elle
reste me semble-t-il d'actualité c'est
une préoccupation de santé publique
maintenant arriverons nous à trouver un
juste milieu entre le développement
économique de ce territoire exceptionnel
et la préoccupation de santé publique à
laquelle nos concitoyens ne
comprendraient pas qu'on ne prête pas
encore attention
moi ce que je crois c'est que c'est
surtout pas la fin d'un débat c'est un
débat qui va se poursuivre je suis prêt
si je suis élu à le poursuivre dans des
conditions saines descente normale avec
le monde viticole
hubert poullot effectivement rica
nationaux est un des spécialistes à
l'assemblée avec andy cole tout à fait
mais qu'il n'a pas réussi à infléchir la
loi evin non plus non mais je pense que
au vu de la question qui se pose sur
notre territoire puisque ça les propos
de monsieur pâris cette épine économique
entre situé entre dijon et beaune je le
rappelle même si aujourd'hui les
viticulteurs comme on les nomme ainsi il
faut aussi faire la part des choses
puisque quand on dit viticulteurs on
pense à des secteurs qui ont une très
grande renommée mondiale et qui vente
des vins à des prix très élevés mais
tout le monde n'est pas dans le même
corps et moi je peux vous dire que j'ai
rencontrée l'été des viticulteurs qui
depuis deux ou trois ans en arrière
soufflés airelles une ville leino qui
colle qui nous inquiète et qui risque de
disparaître au profit au profit
effectivement de grandes sociétés qui
vont faire la part des choses qui vont
racheter qui vont s'accaparer je dirais
gentiment ces deux longs alors justement
c'était une autre des questions que
j'avais prévu parce qu'on parle beaucoup
de ça suffit les rues alesi le thérémine
sur ce malgré cette position là
effectivement c'est parti ça fait partie
du rôle du parlementaire de soutenir une
économie comme la viticulture qui est
primordial en plus on le sait tous
je le rappelle gentiment il ya quand
même eu ce classement aux climats de
bourgogne et l'alcoolisme c'est un
problème comme et l'alcoolisme est un
problème mais la question de fond qu'il
faut se poser est ce que finalement les
gens qui abusent de l'alcool
est ce que ce sont des gens qui
consomment des bouteilles je le dis
clairement
entre 80 ou 100 ou 150 euros je ne le
crois pas du tout donc il faut faire la
part des choses il faut ouvrir le débat
il faut ouvrir le débat et puis faire la
part des choses entre les gens qui
consomment de l'alcool tous les jours
qui en abusent
malheureusement parce que ça il faut le
freiner et puis entre les gens qui ne
fabrique pas je dirais un alcool mais
qui fabrique un produit de terroir de
notoriété mondiale
c'est là la différence on voit on voit
que ce débat est pas simple comment
faire la différence entre ceux qui
consomment du bon vin du vin moyen du
vin en fonction du prix moi je me lance
pas dans un débat comme celui ci
franchement par contre je pense le vrai
sujet de la viticulture au delà de
celui-ci sont des sujets beaucoup plus
forts qu'ils sont seuls augmentation
anormale dans certaines zones du prix du
foncier lui défoncer au khalife
réfléchir c'est aussi le problème me
semble-t-il j'ai rencontré pas mal de
viticulteurs mais bien avant j'étais
sous préfet de l'arrondissement donc
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais le vrai
problème c'est un problème de famille et
transmission du bien s'est il n'y a pas
que la viticulture qui est touché mais
est-on capable de l'agriculture en
général avec une mobilisation de capital
que chacun connaît et donc comment est
ce qu'on arrive à faire que sans fouler
aux pieds le droit successoral mais
comment est ce qu'on peut moi je suis
prêtre avec quiconque et demain y
compris avec hubert poullot comment est
ce qu'on peut améliorer cette situation
pour faire que finalement quand les
camps noviny sont achetés c'est souvent
une situation qui découle de
l'incapacité de la fratrie de payer des
soultes parce que il ya un niveau de
foncier qui est excessif donc si une
vraie réflexion de l'enfant pour tours
10 recherche des points qui peuvent vous
séparer mais j'ai un peu de mal sur ce
sujet non ben c'est un sujet d'intérêt
je vais vous lire je suis je suis né à
gevrey-chambertin j'allais peut-être
déjà dit et souligné en permanence on
voit effectivement les problèmes de nos
viticulture quand de nos viticulteurs
quand il rentre dans des phases de
succession c'est quand même aujourd'hui
on est à moi j'entends les élus locaux
dire ça depuis que ces métiers de faire
les gens tant les vignerons se plaint de
la même chose il rien n'a changé sauf
que y arrive à un moment ça changerait
maintenant et ben pourquoi justement
c'est là que je vais revenir sur une
autre question pourquoi donner une large
majorité à notre président si
effectivement les différentes familles
politiques ne sont pas représentés comme
on a pu le constater au premier tour des
présidentielles je le rappelle est quand
même où on avait quatre familles
politiques qui étaient sensiblement
identique à 4 5% près et si les choses
n'ont pas changé on peut considérer que
les électeurs aient envie de donner la
majorité à une autre famille tu étais
pas l'âge sauf que là où deux familles
comme vous dites qu'est ce qu'elle fera
je me sépare ce qu est ce qu il s excuse
d
ce sujet sera abordé est ce que le débat
sera ouvert
justement avec un va-et-vient de
question de modification d'amendements
pour arriver à arrêter un moment donné
une loi qui par exemple pourrait
permettre de reconnaître au lieu de
prendre ça comme une dans une succession
mais de reconnaître c'est un outil de
travail parce qu'une vigne comme une
terre agricole c'est un outil de travail
pour livre c'est aussi un objet
d'investissement ces derniers lui est
donc sauf que j'aurai du jura a classé
dans notre cas aujourd'hui quand vous
avez des domaines viticoles qui sont à
vendre et bien on voit qui fait les
acquisitions aujourd'hui on est dans
malheureusement dans un pays où les gens
qui ont les capacités financières de
faire ces acquisitions alors plus ça
c'est un point très précis qui peut vous
séparez est ce qu'un encadrement des
prix du cou ou une intervention de
l'état sur le prix des terres c'est
quelque chose qui est envisageable alors
normalement parce qu'en général est un
cadre qui peuvent quand ils peuvent pas
acheter des terres parce qu'un
investissement arrive un investisseur
arrive et demande qu'on encadre les prix
puis quand on veut où il veut le vendre
ils veulent pas qu'on encadre les prix
donc c'est compliqué comme sujet cet
encadrement normalement il existe il ya
des structures qui existent
la safer alors qu'aujourd'hui tout est
pas partout peut-être mais sauf
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement il faut
peut-être voir certaines réglementations
et des fonctionnement de ces structures
qui justement arrive à maîtriser et
évite les hausses que l'on constate
aujourd'hui lé jeu
je vous coupe parce qu'il nous reste
sept minutes cinq minutes d'émission sur
un sujet qui peut être que vous divisez
on en a déjà parlé tout à l'heure mais
c'est un thème quand même centrale dans
le programme des modèles macron j'y
reviens c'est la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
on sait qu'une grande partie des
français on sera exonérée
c'est la ressource principale des
petites communes j'ai parlé ce que vous
avez dit quoi vous gens aux maires des
petites communes que vous rencontriez
qui sont inquiets de ne plus avoir
d'argent pour refaire leur voirie leur
salle défunt j'en ai rencontré des
dizaines
qu'est ce que j'aurais dit des choses
assez simples à faire
oui mais la taxe d'habitation c'est un
des impôts les plus injustes qui
existent les plus injustes qui dit
suivant le taux levée par la commune
suivant la zone à laquelle vous habitez
suivant suivant et ça a été dit je crois
par yolaine courson j'entendais le débat
et la raison yolaine c'est surtout en
zones urbaines que la taxe est moins
cher en zone rurale qu'elle plus cher et
cherchez l'erreur c'est là celle inverse
des capacités productives des deux de
nos concitoyens donc il fallait arrêter
il fallait arrêter cette question l'état
s'est engagé à compenser à l'euro près à
leurs prêts la taxe d'habitation des
collectivités territoriales et ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on fait 80 %
de nos concitoyens à peu près ne
paieront plus de taxe d'habitation 80%
dès lors que vous avez un revenu qui est
approximativement pour un couple à 5000
euros par mois vous ne payez plus de
taxe d'habitation c'est extrêmement
important
pardonnez moi ces deux programmes il me
semble-t-il une petite différence entre
nous c'est que je le connais vous ne
connaissez pas donc c'est 80% population
extrêmement importante c'est un vrai
gain c'est un vrai gain de pouvoir
d'achat en gros si on prend la moyenne
très basses ces 40 ou 50 euros de
pouvoir d'achat par mois c'est pas nul
pour nous reste une réponse d'une
réponse vous n'êtes pas d'accord réussi
à trouver quelque chose sauf que voilà
on peut continuer je vais vous en
trouvez des thèmes
cette mesure nous inquiète fortement je
fais partie en même temps des élus de
terrain dont j'en suis fier pourquoi
elle nous inquiète tout simplement c'est
que déjà il faut quand même se souvenir
45 % aujourd'hui des foyers ne payent
pas la taxe d'habitation déjà alors je
ma crainte aujourd'hui c'est que ça a
été un effet d'un ouvrier en arrière
vous voulez les payer laissez moi finir
merci
sauf que l'inquiétude qu'on a en tant
qu'élu c'est effectivement comment on va
être compensées 7,7
cette perte parce qu'aujourd'hui on va
la perdre alors on vous dit quand vous
dites qu'elle sera compensée à l'euro
près par l'état oui aujourd'hui en 2000
peut-être l'année prochaine en 2018 et
après si ce montant est figé au vu de ce
qui s'est passé ces cinq dernières
années où finalement on en a vu les
collectivités avec ses baisses de
dotations
on a vécu ces baisses de relations
depuis trois ans demain ça va être en
plus parce que il faut quand même le
rappeler dans les projets du nouveau
gouvernement
cette continue aussi 7 cette baisse est
et demain on aura en plus à supporter
cette taxe d'habitation qui serait il
supprimer en partie
deuxième élément qui est quand même pas
des moindres l'état du fait qui va
diminuer cette taxe d'habitation
ils valent attribué à une catégorie de
personnes c'est lui qui décidera du taux
effectivement de cette taxe d'habitation
que va devenir les élus dans un conseil
municipal aujourd'hui avec le transfert
la clé est ce que ce serait pas plus
équilibré que toute la france est un
toufik une catégorie de nîmes et alors
est ce que oui c'est mais ça c'est aussi
des débats qu'il faut avoir
parce qu est-ce qu aujourd'hui une
personne qui vit dans un village de 170
habitants
est ce qu'il est logique qu'elle paye le
même taux sur les mêmes bases que pour
son pavillon qu'une personne qui vit
dans un dans une zone urbaine qui
équiper différemment sur ce terrain
pardonnez moi parce que c'est pas
possible
aujourd'hui l'inquiétude des élus c'est
avec ces baisses de dotations et le la
décision qui appartient jusqu'à
aujourd'hui au maire et au conseil
municipal de décider du ton de ces taxes
d'habitation et le foncier à mon avis y
suit de près ce qui veut dire que avec
la création de ces nouvelles communautés
de communes qu'on a connue récemment
qu'est ce qu'il reste dans les communes
lourd myrianne et ma crainte aujourd'hui
7 voire mal
heureusement disparaître dans quelques
années la totalité de nos communes
petites communes monsieur boulot je
trouve au final que vous êtes un assez
bon avocat de la défense de la taxe d'un
de la tag c'était une boutade fait de la
défense de la taxe d'habitation dont 80
% de nos concitoyens seraient exonérés
parce que quand je vous entends le
schéma me paraît tellement compliqué que
faisons simple faisons simple c'est une
des bases du programme des manuels la
confusion saint cyr ajoute quand même le
fait ne l'oublions pas c'est qu'on à
l'état d' associer française et de son
économie fiq l'on entend bien on est
bien par des mois on est quand même bien
obligés de veiller à la diminution de la
dépense publique à la dépense publique
c'est autant celle de l'état que celle
des collectivités territoriales
saint-prot nous simplement il faudra
être dans un dans une forme de
convergence progressive et il faut
l'entamer que quelques vraiment prendre
sauf sauf que l'état depuis des années
avec sa décentralisation année desservis
sur différentes collectivités qu'on
connaît tous ce soit les communes les
communautés de communes etc
les régions les départements et avec
quels moyens il faut assurer ses
compétences malheureusement les
compétences ont été transférées
financièrement ils n'ont pas été
transférés en même temps il ya son doux
il ya sans aucun doute une réflexion
territoria la poursuite avait sur
l'organisation territoriale française il
ya un cadenas ça fait partie de notre
objectif et ce sera d'autres débats nous
voilà à la fin justement déjà mais oui
déjà
ce débat à tous 30 minutes pourtant il
est temps de conclure 30 secondes à peu
de choses près chacun dans un entrelacs
tirés au sort avant l'émission et on
commence par vous didier parez quelques
mots très court me sembles team nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à perdre de temps
doit pas continuer à perdre de temps
l'état de la société au plan économique
au plan social au plan sécuritaire et à
d'autres éléments suppose une réaction
rapide donc nous souhaitons dans
l'esprit des manuels mâcon dans l'esprit
du gouvernement pluraliste qui a été mis
en place avec edouard philippe nicolas
lau et d'autres je vais pas vous citer
un gouvernement
nous souhaitons pouvoir avancer sur
cette question là il nous faut une
majorité claire
sinon le résultat ça va être de nouveau
une forme d'immobilisme qu'on a trop
connu
il faut arrêter de penser que les
français ne font pas le choix ils ont
fait un choix
je pense qu'il faut reconnaître ce choix
simplement encore faut-il qu'ils soient
confirmés pour terminer je m'adresse à
je m'adresse au boulot je lui dis la
main est tendue à la main est tendue à
lui de la prendre
merci didier berthelot et bien moi je
pour compléter vos remarques tous les
français n'ont pas fait le choix
effectivement d'élire un président de la
république que je respecte et que je lui
souhaite de réussir ce que j'ai dit au
début de mes propos ce qui n'empêche que
le deuxième tour aujourd'hui rien n'est
joué
je suis confiant effectivement quand on
voit la différence de deux devoirs
c'est vrai qu'elles sont importantes
mais quand on voit aussi en rapport
l'abstention est effectivement des
transferts de voix qui peuvent se faire
aujourd'hui moi j'en appelle à la
responsabilité de tous les électeurs qui
à un moment donné attentes des services
de l'état et payent des impôts de faire
le bon choix et surtout de ne pas avoir
une trop large majorité à l'assemblée ce
qu'on risque de rencontrer puisque ça
serait négatif pour notre pays de donner
un chèque en blanc tout simplement
réflexion aimé et surtout arriver à
remonter ce taux d'aps date d'abstention
vous le voyez se remet à partir de fin
merci à tous les deux d'être venus
débattre merci à tous pour l'eau merci
et on se retrouve dimanche bien sûr pour
cette ce deuxième tour des élections
bonsoir
[Musique]